welcome back to the lobby I'm very happy
to be joined by the folks from Bossa
studios Lucan and rekd on my friends hey
great to have you on the show all the
way over from London town yes that clean
are you enjoying the weather over here
in the west coast of the states yes I
think any book t-shirts and I think he
thought it's warmer oh really well then
here's Californian goes asked me lovely
yeah and it wasn't sunday and it's kind
of going on yeah it's come back to sort
of an early not as bad as the rest of
America we know covered in snow yeah
yeah I think this is the only part of
America that's not covered on there like
Twilight 50 feet of snow was at MIT have
like a help sub MIT where they have like
a three-story pile of snow outside one
of the buildings yeah it's a it's pretty
ridiculous edition was like that so for
the folks who might not the word boss
the studio sort of triggers something in
their head but they don't know who
exactly why I tell us about some of the
games you've made some appoint my stone
first surgeon simulator and I am Brett
moment yeah yeah and now words adrift
yes is one of the weekends are working
on parallel to try and bread looking
forward to talking to you guys about
that especially as it sort of it's a
little bit different to what some foam
used to so like surgeon simulator was a
game that came out sort of the same way
games like goat simulator have where
there's like this really interesting
initial hook and it like Keeks people's
interest and then they see videos of the
game and realize oh there's actually
quite a lot to this how did the game
calm about how did you come up with so
that was global game jam 2013 I mean
three other guys she went Long's like a
nearby college in london and just kind
of decided to go kind of stupid make
ourselves laugh because we were going to
be awake for hours right what was the
hook cuz there's usually like a
one-sentence like hook for a game jam
right that you have to like have like
yeah yes it's basically like a theme and
the theme of this that years was just a
sound of a heartbeat okay and we went
literal yeah that's electric ago oh and
then the result was there was a similar
yeah and then it kind of like the monday
after the game download literally like
within 24 hours of finishing it it kind
of went all over I was like YouTube and
there's always buzz about it and we had
no idea like
we yeah we were taking complete by
surprise yo as well like there we no
idea we stopped on the tracks and say
okay stop everything guys get all your
projects just get together and then
let's take certain forward and then we
hold 48 days later we released on Steam
that's crazy yeah we did this 48 hours
into 48 day yeah yeah good segue there
and now look few weeks ago when we hit
two million kind of sales on on surgeon
yeah yeah so when you're doing the game
jams is it mostly just like flex your
muscles as a creative or did you
actually go into those thinking oh we
might end up coming out with something
like was it that surprising ya know to
get gems are the same we always try and
use new formats and new themes and new
constraints and new freedoms the only
thing we never did was anything goes
because when when we tried that once or
we never did we did once the first one
well yeah the first six games or so we
didn't came up is that like a little bit
of restriction sort of forces you out of
your comfort zone yeah get to get you
get your creativity but as good as you
we work with our parents years we have
different kind of teams like the iron
bread team well the drift team was
talking about and the games are great
could you start working with different
people and they're like you don't really
know what's going to come out of it I
mean IIM bread was a year and a half
after kind of the whole surge and stuff
yeah we had 50 or 60 kind of game ideas
in between that time oh really um that
never just made exactly yeah you kind of
you get a good feeling sometimes just
from the reaction from other people in
the studio and stuff when when a kind of
game is starting to kind of come
together so how did I impreza end up
being the game that he wanted to go go
with um it was we check out this hot
gameplay by and bread there's a game jam
last year and i found the idea of like
with surgeon we had like the one task
that we give you which is like perform a
heart transplant right really simple
easy to understand kind of wears not
really simple but it's easy to
understand and with iron bread i like
the idea of just a piece of bread who
would want to become toast and that's it
like so every level you go into it's
like become toast and that's something
that kind of players to understand and
kind of get behind our then we just
messed around with trying to get
controls right see actual game jam was
just how do we get that movement how do
you how do you
bread around level but you can you can
control sticker then just use a to jump
right but then you're just replacing a
character with a piece of bread and
that's not very interesting yeah so the
whole kind of like four corners and
flopping it around those kind of you
know at the end of the game jam it kind
of worked and we saw it more like yeah
there's actually there's something there
like I think the key thing is something
that you can get good at like Serge and
everyone who first place is awful yeah
but then you see the speed runs and the
World Records and these geysers dextrous
is like like it was a real handy I'm
like you were saying before and we it's
a game that all of the controls and all
of what the player can do is actually
doable from the start of the game it's
not like you're leveling up or like
giving them new abilities or anything no
no it's very satisfying yeah it's all on
you you progress as a player right then
and also the other aspect is that you
kind of 4shared what you can do in the
game well maybe if I drop from that
ledge or grab that brick and throw into
the car windshield that can get inside
the car and when you realize it can
actually do that it's such a such a good
surprise and and I think the controls
came out of debt as well is the surprise
of okay I can move the breath around
like very poorly like this and all of a
sudden you realize you can flip and
rotate and 7s about general to
understand the weight of the Bretton
yeah kind of its floppiness and they can
kind of like swing and wrap themselves
around like shelves and then making
climb that way and it's yeah it's this
kind of are you like masters of QWOP is
that a lot I've no idea I don't know we
don't know he does a few times terrible
I was just thinking actually like most
developers have to explain to their
parents like how weird their job is like
I work on this thing or like for you
guys it's actually quite a lot weirder
yeah I made a game where you get to
control people always outside what kind
of games you can get like so I just
seemed I know I'm Brendan go what's that
and it's like oh you control one hand
yep presumably we're not telling you
made surgeon severe they think you're
making like medical research software
yeah that's the first reaction people
don't play games at all right okay
that's very nice for that we actually
got once I think it was a rare door
Eurogamer someone from a teenage ass
stop by oh yeah
and they left the card and everything
was getting [ __ ] they were like oh you
want any kind of my medical sort of like
you know advice or like someone like
consulting right yeah patient I like I
don't think it's the right game for that
that's great I i was talking to armin
when the guys from a goat simulator and
they said that they had people are
reaching out to them as goat experts
yeah saying like oh if you want I could
consult with you for a nominal fee
unlike really interesting things about
goats so apparently it's indicative of
all of games yeah I think its memory you
attach a similar to it right here and
some games like playing I don't know if
you played that one and you know one
where you're simulating a plague
spraying across the world in that they
like they tied in with the the CDC in
like to get that kid to be accurate
afterward like I think the game came out
first and the CDC reach down like here's
how we can make this even more of a
react accurate simulation of this well
yes kind of dark at the Apollo expansion
but I don't know yet no no it's earlier
you're actually spreading the disease
that yeah you know fighting yes no
endemic but yeah your mother's murder
everyone in the world yeah but the CDC
who did like a how fast improper zombie
apocalypse would spread the right-sized
really they investigated world warcraft
because way back yeah you had the virus
then he'll actually yeah that someone
took from a dungeon hmm and my unleashed
in the capital cities neurone was dying
and then yeah said like I think he's he
already interested yeah how it spread
and cuz it was kind of like the first
virtual disease spread that like you've
kind of its weird games getting into all
sorts of interesting areas and you guys
have you ever like been criticized for
those games out there that are clearly
made for like oh we're trying to get
twitch and like youtubers to play these
games you know let's come on up with a
zany idea like something like meme Ron
sort of pops into mind where it's
actually not very good game at all and
but it's like it's clearly made for just
people to play for the sake of it and
air control is another one that came out
last year d do you guys could get that a
lot and he's degree they get for Bradley
Roby surgeon not because certain was one
of the one of the big ones who brought
first ones yeah yeah do I really like
coming sales out of that kind of thing I
think then people you know yeah they set
the precedence but the 09 breath we got
a little bit of a flag saying that our
show you to bay
and so on and it took a while for the
first let's place to come out and people
realize it's actually gameplay involved
yeah because that's how we start we
start the core gameplay and always is
the theme comes afterwards yeah they're
like two days to make these games you
don't have time to no no in two days you
can barely get something working right
if you have a throw all these
requirements on top has to be good for
you to rest via is any idea who end up
with nothing yes ooh maybe that's not
the methodology you've taken world's
adrift like how is this card game come
out of the head of your studio is it
another game jam situation um yeah it
was a game John slightly more ambitious
game jam and again it's taking that kind
of physics thing and then something that
is a base skill that doesn't change
throughout the game you can get really
good at in this instance it's very much
like a I mean a Spider Man esque like a
rattling hook there's a not been very
many kind of good spiral I know there
was a really good-running on the
playstation 2 ways 82 exam yet we had a
look at that one because that was what
everyone went to and went that's how you
do like swinging mechanics yeah we're
kind of like that when it's got like the
nurse sure and all that kind of stuff
that feels very nice so we we definitely
looked that one but with this you can
assign maseeh wherever you attach and so
if you can be swinging for a forest and
you can manually attach a rope to every
single branched and because of the way
we so it takes a while to learn and yeah
yeah like you know like surgeon style
and I'm bread but when you get really
good at you get really good at and we've
seen people like fleeing themselves off
of their ships and launching on to
someone else's then taking them out that
way that's just that the starting point
because the whole game the whole game is
physics-based thanks to our chaps at
probable helping you out with the
underlying engine but things like if you
attach four or five people to an engine
on a ship you can your weight is going
to rip it off axle and you can fling
yourself because the you can actually
rotate you can entangle though yeah they
wrote my wraps all wrapped around yes if
you like some swinging you hit an object
you you kind of build up speak and
suddenly it's like one and and that's
how you can catapult yourself or other
things people or even grappling hook to
a propeller that yes citizen oh boy
ownership just like harpoons like one of
their engines and yank it clean offer
than their ships kind of flying all
wonky you know the color reminds me a
bit of Just Cause multi
Clara yeah and they have really fun with
that sort of stuff yeah I'm the game
itself it seems much more serious than
some of the other games I'm sure other
people you know look at surgeons as
in-depth as those can be surgeon
simulator nine breath they're kind of
silly but it seems like you guys
actually learned a lot from those that
you're able to bring to this yeah it's
it's just it's a big a game for sure but
we have moments of silliness like
because we're like swinging around we
love our kind of physics and stuff like
if you swing yourself into a rock or
into a tree branch your character get
knocked down I just dangle there on the
rope so you're kind of left like one or
a ball and that kind of sauce fun to do
but yeah I mean in the grand scheme of
things it's uh it's you kind of
gathering a crew if you want and you all
kind of invest yourself in this one ship
yeah they build the ships as well yeah
you build the ships then you can
basically just you fly off to the
different kind of those islands its kind
of wind waker skies of arcadia are
inspired we you see their silhouettes
and listen should like i want to go
there and then you can kind of traverse
through kind of weathers and storms and
i'll see you can run into other players
who may attack or may not attack you and
stuff like yeah there's a lot of
emergent gameplay as well which is a
hallmark of both better than surgeon and
we we have no idea how the players are
going to interact and create the rules
how how they going to board another ship
what tactics they will come up with yeah
destroy their engines and take over
their ships etc is that's what we hope
for people using the game that we
created to make stuff that we cannot
imagine that he'd be done looking the
latest play test where you on a ship
kind of firing another one and one of
the players from that [ __ ] was like I've
got to take out him three he swung down
swung onto the ship without him
realizing grabbed another can on the
deck and then just clean just shot his
hand him in the cannon went flying off
cuz you're kind of touch to these little
like see it or tires and him the cannons
went flying off the edge of the ship and
then I was it like it taken out the
threat oh yeah there's a filter my
horrible death it could be the three
ships firing at each other as but like
we knew I'd no idea you could really do
that yeah we didn't know we never knew
that it could be done yeah we knew the
ship should obviously like kind bits
with detach but when someone went and
just grabbed another tire on the same
ship and when I'm just fight it at the
deck is that like an important thing for
you guys in terms of like get you've
always been very good at getting your
games out to people so like with surgeon
when surgeon came out you actually add
loads of stop to it but presumably based
on some feedback you got from the
community and I am bread is the same
situation you've still got a team
working on a right
no yeah have you taken like that similar
methodology world's drift because i
remember the first trailer you put out
was very much a like let us know what
you think yeah come players and should
this be an idea that we go with you know
are you listening to the queers how much
do you listen to community we have to
listen far more what everything that
went a lot of the stuff went in certain
in a lot of stuff that going into bread
right now comes from the community they
asked for our let's but let's put the
the bag at a mms but the free roaming
mode they asked it a lot for that but
they are smaller gangs we can see the
beginning of the game and visualize it
and say it's a good game you put a VTOL
people get interested in we carry on
development and early access or whatever
but with words adrift is different
because such a good such a huge
enterprise so we have to do that for
form from the beginning and it's already
paying off i think that the third video
we put out we we focus on a little bit
on gathering resources and crafting yeah
yeah it is not the the core game at all
but who was an aspect of the game we
just finished doing so we showed up and
people didn't enjoy it as much as the
rest of the game ya later be my all know
it's just another survival game yeah
right yeah I don't we have none of the
like taking care of your character and
like feeding them we're not interested
in nights it's my kind of preserving
your your airship in a way and making
sure you can kind of keep on flying yeah
but nothing informed us to say okay we
need crafting we need gathering but this
is enough now we move on to other stuff
yeah more interesting and so on so
measuring those reactions from people's
not like they are telling us what to do
but they are guiding our hand in which
we travel we focus on it's so much
better to do that way to release a
gaming realized that we did so many
mistakes along the way once it's at then
it's almost too late or yeah is that but
yeah address those issues and so for
folks for watching there who wants to
get in and play it as early as possible
and I felt like a sign up on your
website like yeah how can they get in
and actually like walls drift calm we
have you can just email sign up or
whatever just keep tabs on now we have
like a blog post every week we're kind
releasing new information and stuff are
then eventually when we do get to cause
some clothes bays and stuff will kind of
send that few invites and kind of get
people into there yeah I don't know if I
like to do things as early as possible
so we filled up on this this this whole
thing that lets get a feedback so any
idea when we'll get a closed beta
our open beta this year there's
definitely some easy actually product is
the first half of the year yeah do you
think you would ever combined the world
so that as you're going through worlds
adrift you would see like a little piece
of like go into a cable that goes move
it I'll be incredibly naughty that isn't
any kind of surgeon or bread references
at some point you're gonna feel like the
boss a universe yeah yeah everything's
tied in together yeah including like
your old facebook games all existing
yeah well yeah yeah those are very very
early excellent lots thank you very much
looky i could have very pleasure thank
you so much better than at best love
song we look forward to seeing more of
our was a Jif throughout the rest of
2015 yeah awesome